[Music]
hey Bill I'm getting ready to apply to
college in the near future I've always
loved science but it's never going to
subject to come naturally to me I've
always struggled in it a little bit do
you think that there's a possibility I
could pick science as my major and
become hopefully a scientist one day in
the future despite the fact that it
doesn't come naturally to me thank you
very much
Caitlin of course there's a chance for
you to become a scientist what are you
kidding me of course young woman go for
it there's all sorts of sciences that a
bit will come naturally to you chemistry
and physics may not be your thing or
maybe they're your favorite statistics
always made me crazy although I did it
so yes there's a science for you you're
doggone right
I would please consider pursuing as many
science courses as you can handle don't
you don't have to start with 400 level
courses you know senior in college level
courses just try some I try astronomy
astronomy is empowering and wonderful
it's humbling and empowering all at the
same time try biology the discoveries
being made in genetics right now are
amazing and will change the course of
human history
good try chemistry without chemistry we
would not have these textiles and this
fabulous glass in these electronics that
are enabling us to have this computer
conversation now just go for it of
course big thing I remind everybody
though is algebra algebra is really
important and it was hard for me too you
just got to practice you got to practice
algebra over and over and the reason
it's valuable apparently research
suggests thinking abstractly about
numbers enables you to think abstractly
about all sorts of things so go back if
you need to if you're a junior just do a
little more algebra and I bet you're
more comfortable with the whole idea and
you might change the world go get em
Caitlyn
you